good morning believe nation today's
message is higher your weaknesses over
to you Sarah Blakely and we say as soon
as you can afford to hire your
weaknesses or the things you don't enjoy
as much do it and any time that you can
delegate and clone yourself kind of and
try to get some additional support it
yeah raised moment in a small business
you know I hired my day-to-day CEO about
two years into stardom Spanx and up
until that point you know when you have
no money or every department so I got to
learn very quickly what I'm really
better at what I'm not as good at what I
enjoy doing what I don't enjoy doing and
I couldn't wait to hire someone to do
fill in my weaknesses and just focus on
my strength so the question that they
today is who was the first person you
hire or who is going to be the first
person that you hire in your business
what is they're all going to be for me
the first person I hired was a guy who
did database work for me I hired him for
one hour a week because that freed up
more than hour of my time per week to
let me focus on bigger picture stuff he
was better at doing that task and I ever
would be I didn't want to get good at
that and it was a relief and since they
are continued to build up my team so who
is the first person that you hired what
do they do or who is going to be the
first person that you will hire leaving
the comments below and join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events pressing
ok
an espresso give me go